Ciao a Gu a me anni fa è successo che ero a casa
con il mio ragazzo
dopodiché lui se ne va da casa mia e io
scrivo ad un altro ragazzo con cui stavo
uscendo in quel periodo dicendogli
amore se n'è appena andato ovviamente
quel messaggio l'ho mandato alla prima chat
aperta cioè quella del mio ragazzo ufficiale
ma infatti ti spiego come
faccio io con luigi solitamente ho due cellulari uno e il mio e l'altro
è molto piccolo perché così almeno
li riesco proprio a distinguere perdonami a
questo scempio dico no comunque sono
d'accordo con te vogliamoci bene evviva
miss italia vivi in questo mondo vivi
esci fuori di qua guarda che il mondo è una merda
non l'hai visto ci  sono delle persone
belle ma sono rarità basta credere alla
bontà delle persone basta no, non si
dicono bugie specie di questo tipo
non ci sto andiamo avanti
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è messaggi mandati nella
chat sbagliata
per un tema così delicato ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios de casa mia
una persona che ha un rapporto con il
mio cellulare abbastanza posso dire
tranquillo ecco non cerca ogni due
secondi di prenderne possesso stiamo
parlando niente popò di meno che di
luigi ciao ciao comunque se sembra che siamo
appena svegli è la verità è così sto cercando di
guardare il più possibile capito così
per sembrare sveglio sei pronto via ti
senti pronto abbastanza pensi di
poterla affrontare questa giornata
io non credo se un giorno tornerò nei tuoi pensieri ma è orrenda questa canzone c'avrà tipo cent'anni
beh che vuol dire il lago dei cigni ha più
di cent'anni vai a dire che è orrenda
perché ha più di 100 anni
anche la Mona Lisa ha più di 100 anni
perdonatelo fa la moda ero in
macchina con quella che era la mia
fidanzata ci eravamo lasciati in quel
periodo non stavamo insieme ma comunque
ci vedevamo eravamo in macchina a fare
le cose dopo un po' mi manda
un messaggi mio padre però in quel momento io non lo c**o poggio il telefono sul cruscotto
senonché parte un messaggio vocale
senza che io me ne accorga e nel
frattempo io vado parto dopo un po che
io finisco la accompagno, la mia ragazza, a casa
torno e vedo dal cellulare che è stato mandato a mio padre
un messaggio di 5 minuti mi impaurisco, lo apro e
sento praticamente di tutto dove
praticamente il rumore più normale è
questo per 5 minuti oltre tutti i gemiti
e la mia ragazza che si arrabbia alla fine
perché le metto un dito in **** e si sente lei che
mi urla in faccia dicendo ma sei scemo e cose del genere
io non so se lui l'ha letto non so
niente non ci ho mai parlato da un lato
però mi sento fortunato perché poteva
capitare a chiunque altra persona che
non fosse mio padre quindi già mia
mamma era peggio
già tutti i miei amici tutti i miei gruppi era peggio bravo
mi piace che vedi il bicchiere mezzo pieno mi
sono fatto una risata dai
l'ottimismo ti salverà secondo me ti
farà andare avanti calcola che tu hai appena reso a parole quello che forse
è uno dei miei terrori più grandi il fatto
che parta un vocale quando meno puoi
controllarlo cioè che non deve per forza
essere una situazione intima ma che
parta un vocale di 10 minuti soltanto per dirti ma che sei scemo allora ciao Gu per quanto riguarda
comunque messaggi inviati alla persona
sbagliata
quella persona credo fosse un ragazzo
con cui mi sentivo però io non ero
interessata e al suo ennesimo messaggio
che visualizzavo e non rispondevo faccio
lo screen lo mando a una mia amica dico ma
questo ha proprio rotto il **** per accorgermi a
risposta ricevuta di averlo inviato in realtà a lui stesso però così poi non mi ha
più scritto beh problema risolto e sono riuscita a chiudere perfetto brava hai visto alle volte come la sfortuna può
fare un 360 gradi e trasformarsi così
in fortuna un'altra ottimista cronica
che tenera un giorno stavo al mare a casa mia
vicino a roma con le mie migliori amiche
una delle mie migliori amiche si era lasciata da poco col suo fidanzato e lei ovviamente c'è
stata molto male e quindi ha ben pensato
quella sera di mandargli un messaggio e noi
abbiamo provato a fermarla ma non ci
siamo riuscite
il messaggio lo allego qui sotto aspetta
aspetta aspetta questa è pro "ciao! NOOOOO!"
Oddio ma le senti? "Ciao! NOOOO!" Belle queste sono amiche vere
ti fermano prima di far danni ma ormai
lo aveva fatto, lo aveva mandato e scusa "Ciao! NOOOOO!" ciao Guglielmo
ti mando preso questo screenshot che come vedi è preso da uno di quei soliti gruppi che tutti
abbiamo di famiglia allargata con
nonni zii cugini grandi piccoli bambini
e una mattina mi sveglio e trovo questo
diciamo messaggio di buongiorno sul mio
mio telefono e niente voglio dirti che è
stato mandato da mio zio che ha un tipo
ottantina di anni mentre il messaggio di
sotto è della figlia che cerca in
qualche modo di non so mettere pezze a
quello che è successo io l'ho già letto, io l'ho già letto, io l'ho già letto… sei
pronto lo zio di 80 anni si è superato
vabbè credo che abbia sbagliato un po'
a scrivere perché forse scriveva tipo con
una mano e mezzo con mezza mano
anzi **** duro e bello iuuuu sua figlia scusate
evidentemente il tè di papà ha qualcosa che
non va
li ho chiamati per eliminare i messaggi
ma mamma… non risponde cripta
la mia voce
addirittura i nostri potenti mezzi
trasformeranno la tua voce da questo a
quest'altra cosa vai Enrico
ciao Gu e niente stavo messaggiando su Facebook
con la mia migliore amica e intanto
anche il mio ormai ex fidanzato e a un certo punto scrivo questo
messaggio, stavamo parlando di lui, e gli faccio "non la sa neanche leccare" ovviamente l'ho
mandato a lui la sua risposta è stata
buono a sapersi, almeno mi ci impegno un po' di più la prossima volta
questo può essere un messaggio
costruttivo sto chiamando lo psicologo
scusami tu non hai mai mandato
un messaggio sulla chat sbagliata no in realtà no
magari questi gruppetti ultimamente un
po' di casini sì ma no fortunatamente no io
no perché non hai amici? No in realtà ne ho anche tanti, fin troppi.
Io sai che non ricordo se ho mandato
cioè sicuramente l'avrò fatto io ho un mio
amico, una persona che conosco non
faccio nomi,
una volta ha mandato diciamo un suo
selfie scattato un po' dal basso, ok? A
un suo contatto di lavoro, l'ha
cancellato subito e lui ha fatto scusami
no, ti ho mandato il documento sbagliato e
gli ha mandato un altro documento su
tipo delle rendicontazioni si è stato bravissimo
Hey Gu, ciao buon anno e tante cose belle. Io stavo con questo
ragazzo e mi è capitato di mandare sai tipo
foto di quelle tipo hot… l'ho mandata a sua madre
su messenger e va beh, c'ha messo il like carina
almeno sua madre ha apprezzato che bella ci sta che
ci ha messo il like, eh?
Tipo 'mazza mio figlio buongustaio io pensavo fosse un c******e questo è uno
dei motivi per cui mai avere i numeri di
telefono di suocere, consuocere cose così
io ce l'ho quello di tua madre. Cancellalo subito!
Oddio ma questo è un messaggio vecchio mi hanno
mandato questo. Questo qui ve lo sto facendo vedere solamente per farvi
prendere bene, eh. Nel senso non c'entra
niente col tema di questo video mi
sembri un po tu, sì.
Allora, va beh, ora andiamo al messaggio che ha mandato in
realtà veramente questa ragazza ciao Willwoosh, ciao ospite
spero di essere ancora in tempo per
questo audio comunque durante il periodo
in cui stavo col mio primo ragazzino di
16 anni è successo che eravamo a casa
sua da soli e stavamo facendo le nostre
cosine romantiche. Mi è arrivato un
messaggio da una mia amica chiedendomi se
ero libera per uscire con lei e al
tempo stesso un messaggio di mia madre
chiedendomi dovere ero perché non ero a
casa ho sbagliato a inviare il messaggio
al destinatario e ho inviato il
messaggio a mia madre con scritto
"guarda anna sto s******o" io tipo non sono tornata
a casa per otto mesi. No, no, lei è ancora
fuori latitante. Lei sono anni ormai che
non torna a casa. Io credo non mi sia mai capitato di inviare gli screen alla
persona che avevo scrinnato cose simili
però vogliamo parlare di quel periodo
oscuro che ognuno di noi passa e non
dite che non è vero in cui le altre
persone non ti c****o minimamente e quindi
fingi di aver sbagliato a inviare il
messaggio cioè tipo, gli invii un messaggio che
fai finta che non era destinato a quella
persona così tanto per farvi capire
che c***o, esisti anche tu. Una professionista. È
capitato a tutti e lo so. Una
professionista tu non l'hai mai fatto? Probabilmente sì. È
una delle tattiche migliori all'inizio
però posso dire una cosa? Quando usi
quella tattica di essere molto bravo
però perché a me tipo non ha mai
funzionato non riuscirà mai a fare un maledetto audio continuo, comunque ciao
ciao ospite ti volevo raccontare di quando
avevamo il gruppo di classe con la
nostra professoressa di italiano
il mio compagno di classe scrisse
sul gruppo con la professoressa "si s***a" e noi
sconvoltissime "tizio ma che fai?
ma guarda che quello è il gruppo con
la professoressa" e lui subito si corresse
scrivendo "si scherza" con un asterisco. L'asterisco funziona sempre.
L'asterisco è una bella mossa perché
cioè trasformare scopa e scherza cioè sono
molto simili nel senso anche a livello di concetto. Ciao Gu un bel po' di
anni fa quando ancora non si potevano
cancellare i messaggi su Whatsapp.  Stanno
arrivando, scusate, un sacco di frasi che
dicono "quando ancora non si potevano
cancellare i messaggi su Whatsapp"
possiamo dire che quello di cancellare i
messaggi su Whatsapp è stato un atto di
civiltà da parte dei programmatori e
degli ideatori di whatsapp? Assolutamente.
e ho pure ragionato su una cosa. Quale? E
forse è arrivato il momento di dirla. Vai. Non so
se siete pronti ok? Che quando tu
cancelli per tutti e perché in realtà
tu vuoi cancellarlo all'altro contatto
certo ma chi lo cancella solo per se
stesso è per non farsi sgamare ma allo
stesso tempo non farsi sgamare dall'altra
persona che stai cancellando i messaggi e
quindi gli ideatori di Whatsapp
Una volta il fidanzato di una mia
amica inviò una foto del pupazzo di Woody
abbracciato al suo pene eretto solo che
invece di inviarlo a lei l'ha inviato su
un gruppo dove c'erano sia lei, sia tutta
una serie di amici. Questa però è pesante
dai. Era tipo Woody abbracciato al tuo
Wudy. Hai presente i würstel? Due Woody. *francese*
*altra roba in francese*
*Dio mi aiuti francese*
*Ma perché sta succedendo tutto ciò?*
*Forse è uno degli angeli dell'Apocalisse*
Sto scherzando 'mbare
vedi che questa la devi mettere che devo
vedere la tua reazione in video comunque se vuoi la
traduzione fammi sapere ciao. Io ero tipo "sì ma come ho raggiunto
la Francia? Ma in che modo?"
Ma perché? Io già mi sentivo una star
europea. Tipo "Grazie!"
Niente mi hai rovinato la… posso sapere
perché io non parlo minimamente francese
non ci capisco niente
che cos'è che hai detto? Se qualcuno lo
può tradurre mi farebbe un favore. Cioè,
basta che non siano insulti. No, quelli no. Se sono
insulti sappi che ho il tuo Facebook
vediamo chi ride per ultimo, eh? Una delle
mie brutte figure più recenti
praticamente. Vado a Roma. Faccio tante foto
dal finestrino e non mi accorgo che in
una di queste si vede in bella mostra il
pacco di profilattici
E non l'hai visto? Sì che l'ho visto. Era tutto buio e solo il
flash ha rivelato questo particolare
vabbè comunque buon anno a tutti. "Si vedono i
Durex." Lei: "sono caramelle nella tasca
dell'auto" e poi questa foto. Fai finta di non vedere, dai.
Sì, cioè. Questi genitori che devono… ma che c***o.
Cioè, genitori che giocano a un due tre stella
cioè che devi per forza tanare le persone.
A un certo punto un minimo di tatto e
cacchio. Ho amato lei "sono caramelle!" "Sono delle caramelle… Durex".
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
ragazzi se c'è una cosa che ho
imparato è che non sono i robottini che
ti puliscono casa che hanno
permesso alla razza umana di andare
avanti ma la possibilità di cancellare i
messaggi su Whatsapp questo è sinonimo
di civiltà.
Io ho imparato di fare attenzione alle
gocce d'acqua. Cioè non ve lavate piuttosto.
Io come sempre vi ringrazio per
aver seguito questo video. Vi chiedo di
farmi sapere con un commento qua sotto
quali sono stati magari quelle
esperienze legate a dei messaggi
mandati nelle chat sbagliate o magari
se avete dei suggerimenti per dei prossimi
temi in futuro. Come sempre vi invito a
iscrivervi, attivare le notifiche con la
campanellina qua sotto
o qui… non me lo ricordo mai. Ti ringrazio per
essere venuto qui. Grazie a te. Per aver fatto
questo video insieme e adesso andiamo a
magna' e ci vediamo con la prossima
puntata di vita buttata giovedì di prossimo
ciao
aspetta Lu', ho una cosa per te
ti amo tanto
ma non avevi spento… ma è carinissima rifalla subito. E no… il maestro non si ripete.